carrusel de las artes
[Música]
maría carolina piña
bienvenidos una vez más a este espacio
donde les contamos la vibrante
actualidad artística en francia- hoy
daremos un salto al pasado para
descubrir dos magnas civilizaciones
antiguas a través de los objetos que nos
legaron y les hablaremos de cine y de
música francesa
en este programa descubriremos los
secretos del antiguo perú a través de
una exposición inédita sobre machu
picchu en parís que reúne piezas con más
de 3000 años de historia
iremos también al museo más célebre del
mundo el louvre de parís para conocer
tres maravillas egipcias que se
resguardan allí
una película costarricense llega a las
salas francesas clara sola una historia
de emancipación femenina cargada de
realismo mágico
y para festejar la primavera en francia
les hablaremos de la música soleada y
llena de humor de vida el dj que se ha
convertido en una de las revelaciones de
la escena musical francesa
[Música]
hoy hacemos un viaje en el tiempo hasta
el perú antiguo por primera vez en la
historia piezas artísticas de las
civilizaciones pre incas e incas han
salido de perú para ser admiradas en la
capital francesa una muestra en
inmersión que reúne casi 200 objetos y
que abrió sus puertas a carrusel de las
artes
[Música]
el visitante entra a esta exposición
como si estuviera adentrando a la
ciudadela de machu picchu cumbre y
símbolo del imperio inca machu picchu y
los tesoros de perú reúne casi 200
piezas para entender el extraordinario
desarrollo artístico de los incas y de
las civilizaciones del antiguo perú
[Música]
acá en esta exhibición presentamos 3000
años de desarrollo cultural partimos con
culturas diferentes
chavín cupisnique vicus mochica
lambayeque y chimú hasta los incas esto
se cuenta a través de materiales
maravillosos
cerámicas modeladas esté pintadas
textiles suntuosos este textiles de
plumas tejidos pectorales joyas de oro y
plata y todos estos objetos conforman un
discurso narrativo un sistema visual de
comunicación
los incas aprendieron de las
civilizaciones que los precedieron
adoptaron su cosmovisión y las creencias
en tres mundos el superior el de los
muertos y el de los hombres la serpiente
que es el símbolo del mundo de los
muertos este la serpiente la vamos a ver
representada de diferentes formas
estéticas en diferentes objetos pero se
refiere a este mundo el ave es igual el
felino también bueno el felino también
es un símbolo de poder fuerte de los
líderes políticos religiosos que
asimilan estos poderes de los animales
sagrados para poder gobernar
en parís pueden admirarse suntuosas
joyas de una gran factura de oro y plata
metales sagrados para los habitantes del
perú antiguo
el oro representa al sol el sol
representa el mundo de arriba el mundo
de los dioses es masculino la plata
representa la noche representa la luna
representa lo femenino representa el
mundo de abajo la madre tierra el útero
materno es lo que tenemos que hacer
cuando vemos estas piezas en vez de
mirar una joya como la veríamos en
cualquier joyería en realidad lo que
tenemos que ver es todo el trasfondo de
cómo se hizo con tanta mística pensando
que hacerla de esa forma es lo que
impulsaría al círculo de la vida a que
siempre se está regenerando machu picchu
y los tesoros de perú se completa con
una visita de realidad virtual para una
vertiginosa experiencia en inmersión
[Música]
y del periodo antiguo nos vamos al museo
del louvre para descubrir a su
impresionante colección de antigüedades
egipcias monumentos sarcófagos y objetos
de la vida diaria ocupan dos plantas de
este museo parisino para intentar
reconstituir cinco mil años de historia
en egipto nos lo cuenta melissa barra
[Música]
el museo de lujo es el guardián parisino
del arte egipcio más de 6000 obras
abarcan cinco milenios de historia
faraónica durante el antiguo imperio los
primeros faraones fueron enterrados en
mastabas o tumbas monumentales el lujo
conserva la capilla de la mastaba de aje
tot gp ofrecida a francia por egipto a
principios del siglo 20 y está cubierta
de frescos sobre la vida al borde del
nilo 2500 años antes de cristo
[Música]
se ven los pescados que los egipcios
solían comer las técnicas de trillado de
grano usando ovejas o métodos de cosecha
imagen de un pobre metal
el pasillo de esfinges es otra maravilla
egipcia en la época se creía que llevaba
hacia la tumba sagrada del dios ptah la
esfinge es un ser híbrido tiene cuerpo
de león y cabeza humana pero no
cualquier cabeza tiene un némesis o sea
un tocado de rey mezclando la fuerza
guardiana del león y la cabeza soberana
este animal legendario encarna el poder
faraónico
esta momia es la protagonista de lugo
junto con la colección de sarcófagos nos
recuerda la importancia que tenían los
ritos funerarios en la civilización
egipcia azúcar lo fácil de la
momificación la momificación como los
jeroglíficos o las ofrendas son maneras
de enviar al más allá el cuerpo físico
para que el alma pueda reconocerlo una
vez llegado a sus destinos así el muerto
puede aprovechar de su vida eterna esta
momia muestra por ejemplo el vendaje
extremadamente minucioso que se
realizaba en una momificación
200 años después de que johnson polio
descifrar a los jeroglíficos la
colección egipcia de luz sigue
fascinando a millones de visitantes del
mundo entero
[Música]
y de estreno en las pantallas de cine
francesas claras o la ficción cargada de
realismo mágico y que nos transporta a
las montañas de costa rica nosotros
conversamos con la directora y la
protagonista de esta cinta presentada en
la quincena de los realizadores del
festival de cannes
[Música]
ah
en un pueblito perdido en costa rica una
mujer de 40 años con un grave problema
en la columna vive atrapada en un rol
impuesto por su madre devota clara sola
cuenta la emancipación de esta mujer de
la opresión que ejercen la religión la
familia y los hombres como nos dijo la
directora de la cinta natali alvarez mes
en esta peli nace mucho como de un deseo
de hablar del deseo y no es tanto la
religión sino las normas que vienen con
la religión que tienen que ver con la
vida cotidiana ya ni siquiera con la
religión que es que es como que se
inmiscuyen y pasan por tradición no
siempre ha sido así y siempre hay que
sonreír pónganse tacones calladita
me molestan mucho y bueno otras frases
que uno reconoce que no solo dicen de la
misma manera de los hombres ahora cada
hora la bailarina costarricense wendy
chinchilla interpreta a clara una mujer
en contacto directo y sensorial con la
naturaleza y los animales aquí en la
cámara sigue en su despertar sexual y
espiritual se habla como de si son mujer
osos
guapa y entonces te vas a casar y si no
lo haces entonces sos santa y hay una
cosa que pasa digamos con esta violencia
de la que hablábamos y no es que el
precio la mamá ella sea salvaje ni sea
mala y si es cariñosa pero ella cree que
eso lo correcto como debe de criar a su
hija porque esa es lo que ella cree no
entonces no es como que haya un mala ni
que es terrible sino que ella lo hace
desde ese lugar pensando que es lo
correcto lo mejor que le puede dar a su
hija ni es probablemente lo mejor que le
pueda ver si es que lo que ella puede
dar
y llegó el momento de la música en
carrusel de las artes con natalia
olivares hola natalya hoy nos presentas
a un dj electro humorístico que es
oriundo de lila en el norte de francia
pero que ha conquistado todo el país
smith un antihéroe de la música francesa
dj productor sacó un último álbum que se
llama born loser en torno a un personaje
excéntrico fuera de todos los dictados
estéticos y de moda y su objetivo era
hacer una música para bailar así lo
describe en todo caso el mismo
[Música]
yo diría que mi música es solar es una
música para bailar con una pequeña pizca
de melancolía porque nosotros los
franceses somos todos un poco románticos
yo sé muy bien de dónde soy soy del
norte de francia de lyle es verdad soy
diferente pero no diría que soy un ovni
musical
[Música]
no es un ovni musical según él pero si
su universo es de que a leo fuera de
foco como se dice acá y funciona
perfectamente su objetivo era hacer esta
música para bailar pero también en torno
a todo un universo del humor de lo
absurdo como por ejemplo en esta canción
que se llama all inclusive
hoy
hemos filmado este videoclip como un
documental yo me fui de vacaciones a
bordo de un crucero con la realizadora
la directora francesa alize mo aquí
hemos filmado todo con un teléfono sin
avisarle a las personas que filmábamos
durante una semana estuvimos haciendo
cualquier cosa jugando con los niños
tirando los al agua baile encima de la
mesa del desayuno con una pareja de
viejitos
se observa para mí no tanto
[Música]
mucha risa mucha risa mucha risa de
maría carolina sí mucho humor pero
detrás detrás existe un real mensaje así
lo promete me lo explica el mismo
joseba tots es una crítica acerca de
estos barcos que navegan en el
mediterráneo que se llaman all inclusive
'todo incluido' pero al final no ofrecen
nada vemos el mar todo el día pero no
podemos bañarnos en él se trata de abrir
un poco los ojos sobre lo absurdo que es
ese sistema que es viajar con el culo en
una silla frente a una piscina insertada
en un edificio como de cemento que se
mueve por el mar
y el
sol
gracias natalia por presentarnos a este
artista que tiene un éxito rotundo en
las radios y en la escena musical
francesa y justamente vamos a despedir
este programa con su canción time time
que es de crono music with it y me de
una parodia de los rumanos son para
despedirnos muchísimas gracias por su
sintonía y hasta la próxima jaua
[Música]
con teresita la mamá con un pene
sí